c'est une déclaration qui pourrait
bouleverser les fondations du système
politique libanais alors qu'ils
semblaient insensibles aux
revendications des manifestants qui
contestent son pouvoir depuis plusieurs
mois le chef de l'état s'est engagé hier
soir sur la voie d'un changement
institutionnel profond michel aoun a
appelé à mettre en place un état laïc en
concertation avec les autorités
religieuses et politiques
je demande que le liban soit déclarée
état laïc
je m'engage à appeler au dialogue des
autorités spirituelles et les dirigeants
politiques afin d'arriver à une formule
acceptable par tous et pouvant être
mises en place à travers des amendements
constitutionnels approprié quelques
heures avant le discours du président
libanais le chef du hezbollah s'était
lui aussi dit prêt à discuter d'un
nouveau pacte politique pour le pays
l'organisation chiite c'est très
influente dans la vie politique
libanaise et allié de michel aoun
nous sommes ouverts à toutes discussions
calmes sur le sujet mais à la condition
que ce soit la volonté de toutes les
parties
il y à des personnes qui ont peur
d'avoir cette discussion pour un nouveau
pacte politique nous devons respecter
ses préoccupations ces annonces
surviennent alors que les parlementaires
continuent de négocier pour désigner un
nouveau premier ministre après la
démission du gouvernement d'hassan diab
lé 10 août dernier
le poste doit revenir à un musulman
sunnite selon le système confessionnel
censés partager le pouvoir entre les
principales communautés du pays
le mouvement de contestation populaire a
déjà averti qu'il rejetterait tout non
issus de la classe politique actuelle
cette dernière semble pencher en faveur
du diplomate mustapha adib cette
incertitude politique s'ajoute à une
situation économique catastrophique
encore aggravée par la double explosion
du port de beyrouth qui a fait au moins
181 morts et plus de 6500 blessés c'est
dans ce contexte qu'ils emmanuel macron
se rendra ce soir à beyrouth le
président français devrait en profiter
pour accentuer la pression sur les
dirigeants libre
afin qu'ils accélèrent le processus de
réforme